As I said, my name is Spencer Rugaber
and I have been with Georgia Tech for
25 years.
Before that I was an industrial software
developer, both for big companies like
Bell Laboratories in Spery, and for
a startup called Interactive Systems.
Since coming to Georgia Tech I have also
worked closely with industry Both for
the large telecommunications vendor,
and with several startup companies.
Throughout I have tried to combine
academic software engineering theory
with everyday industrial practice.
I am the developer of CS 6310,
and have taught it many times,
both on site in Atlanta, and
remotely in Korea, and France.
I also participated in the planning and
development of other software
insuring courses here at Georgia Tech
including the course on software process
that is part of the ahms program.
And other courses on software
generation and software requirements.
One thing that characterizes
these courses,
is their emphasis on learning by doing.
Particularly for design, no amount of
academic knowledge can make up for
the hard won experience of
actually building things.
You will have that opportunity in
the project portion of this course.
You can have a look at my teaching
philosophy by following the link
in the instructor notes for this lesson.
I now want you to meet Jarrod Parkes.
You will see him in some of the lesson
videos acting as a typical student,
trying to solve the exercises and
asking questions that arise.
Jarrod, can you tell us
a little about yourself.
>> Absolutely, as Spencer said
my name is Jarrod Parkes and
I'll be working with you and
Spencer throughout this course.
In terms of software experience I've
worked in a number of different
places in my career.
I've worked in
a telecommunications company and
there I tested and programmed new
features for dsl routing equipment.
I've also programmed a number of
small video games and prototypes for
the biotech community.
And I own a web and mobile development
company with my twin brother, James.
More importantly,
though, is I want to help Spencer bring
a new, exciting feel to this course.